now this is another day when I say thank
goodness Merrick Garland is not an
associate Justice on the Supreme Court
as imperious as always he emerged today
of course refusing to take any questions
to defend his Department's actions
vis-a-vis the former president Trump
my role has been completely consistent
with the regulations that set forth
responsibilities to the attorney general
under the special counsel regulations
and I followed those regulations
look let's be very clear here the issue
is
are you sir acting in good faith or are
you part of a political operation to get
a conviction of Trump by any means
necessary
81 percent of Republicans believe this
about all you know this is all about
politics and protecting one of the more
destructive uh presidents the United
States has ever had Joe Biden and
they're right now consider the situation
this way No One Believes that Merit
garland would still be AG if he didn't
hadn't greenlit a special prosecutor in
this case
everyone on MSNBC and CNN believes that
Garland is trying to put Trump in jail
no matter where the facts lead otherwise
they would be calling tonight for his
removal it's really not that complicated
and any of the lawyers on TV any of the
presidential candidates or former
officials with really big titles who
claim that Trump is quote toast or act
like this is a slam dunk case they're
embarrassing themselves
they know or should know that every
piece of information about this case has
has been presented by the federal
government to a trump-hating media and
it has been framed in the worst possible
life for him the entire narrative has
been skewed by Jack Smith and Merrick
Garland's doj and it's been presented to
a public that is generally unfamiliar
with how the legal process works or even
what an indictment actually is
but going forward we're going to learn a
lot more about this prosecution the
tactics and the methods of Jack Smith
and his Mary band of prosecutors
and we're going to learn all of it by
the way and if Trump is able to keep
some good lawyers around
it will all be carefully dissected by
his legal team
now one issue is already being raised
regarding the rate of Mar-A-Lago and the
fact that the FBI did not seek consent
from the president's attorneys and even
dismiss concerns raised by its Florida
team
we're going to dig into those issues and
whether the doj tried to subvert the
attorney-client privilege that protects
Communications between Trump and his
lawyers in just moments
now I used to do white-collar litigation
in my lawyering days
the defense doesn't usually tip its hand
before an indictment and that happened
here of course they go into the United
States attorney's office or in this case
the doj and they present their case in
an attempt to get the government to
change their mind and not indict but we
all know that Jack Smith's office in
this case had already made up its mind
the fact is this indictment is the best
they've got
the facts that were outlined in the
indictment the best they've got and I'm
not that impressed there is no evidence
that the president was engaged in an
attempt to profit personally from these
documents or traffic National Security
secrets to foreign entities or even that
he misplaced any of the documents
however with Joe Biden there are
increasingly credible allegations that
he and his family did personally profit
from his position in government as vice
president and president
and to the tune perhaps of millions and
millions of dollars
the sad truth is our media apparently
does not believe there are any real
National Security implications for the
family of a sitting president or vice
president to be setting up shell
companies that will funnel foreign money
back to the family coffers presumably in
exchange for influence why else do they
do it
now think about how this works let's
just say hunter Biden shows up and says
he has a consulting firm and offers His
Brilliant consulting services to
companies and places like Ukraine and
China
now certainly they're not paying for the
business Acumen of this guy
computer they've taken tons of questions
like just left it like that came on he
would always put them again like a
passcode
it was like
is
somebody stole them
so it's all apparently hunky dory with
Jake Tapper in the crowd over at CNN
that this actually takes place not a
security concern
do any of these people with the furrowed
brows over Trump's document storing
habits do any of them at all care that a
U.S senator like Chuck Grassley is
making allegations that our president is
being paid and has been paid by Foreign
interests
if you don't care about that then the
angle is not going to take anything that
any of these media types say about
National Security concerns seriously
because we do have National Security
issues facing us tonight serious ones
and they have nothing to do with Trump
and boxes of documents in a bathroom
do those boxes of Mar-A-Lago documents
cause the 13 service members to be
slaughtered during that botched
Afghanistan pullout
did those boxes at Mar-A-Lago convince
the Pentagon that we now have such a
weakened industrial base that we can't
beat China if they take Taiwan
or did those boxes of documents at
Mar-A-Lago leave our border open to
potential terrorists and now we're
worried about Chinese agents in the
United States
of course the answer is no to all of the
above hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else